we love LaDainian Tomlinson in every way
shape and form he's here on the Rich
Eisen show how are you Elle T I'm doing
wonderful rich how are you well first of
all I've spoken to you since you're a
pro football hall of fame off the air so
on the air congratulations that was an
awesome speech at a great weekend thank
you and also to prove one of the many
reasons why you are in the Pro Football
Hall of Fame as you're coachable and you
take good ideas and you execute them to
perfection and when we told you why not
reveal your bust by tear dropping the
covering off of it you did that did you
not look Danian I did I did and you're
right I take coaching very well and I'm
typically a guy that can do exactly what
the coach asked me to do so you you gave
me you know you gave me the idea and you
kind of ran it down to me of the place
supposed to go and you know the diagram
was perfect and I pulled it off
and you executed it and and just like
just like the old days you had Lorenzo
Neil start to play in a way and you
followed and again before we get to this
the way you finish the speech was
inspiring to many what's been the
follow-up as you were made a call for
unity from the podium in early August in
in Ohio Lt well I think the follow up is
what we will be seeing from the
Cleveland Browns just last week before
the game during national anthem a call
for unity where they had police
department and the fire department lock
arms with the players around the stadium
and that's that's a sign of unity to me
that's what Team America represents all
people all backgrounds all cultures
races doesn't matter coming together to
represent the highest ideals of mankind
and moving this nation forward and so
that was that was extremely great to see
from my point of view LT of the NFL
Network and also from FedEx and we'll
get to that in a moment here on the Rich
Eisen show what do you think Adrian
Peterson's thinking right now today
after everything we saw on Monday night
from the future
he's in few snaps and then the staredown
he had with his coach that he he
backtracked from well I just think he's
he's probably searching within himself
to kind of come to grips with his role
on that team you know maybe he expected
to be a guy to go in and take control in
that backfield and be a 20 carry guy
again but I think the reality is and he
understands he's going to be one of the
running backs by committee in that all
sense and and that's a tough thing to
come to grips with and you know man I
just I just think the quicker that he's
able to say you know what okay I'm only
gonna get five to ten cares a game and
I'm okay with that I'm gonna make the
best of it the faster he's able to come
to grips with that I think the better he
will be for that team because I still
think there's there's value that he
asked to that football team especially
you know in times where they're gonna be
up in the fourth quarter and they need
to close out a game or they need a
touchdown on the goal line or in the red
zone I think he can add value to that
football team but he cannot add value if
he's still thinking that he's gonna be a
20 carry type of guy because he's gonna
be honest on the sideline frustrated
just like he was this past Monday well I
mean part of the frustration had to be
he's in Minnesota right I mean what if
you know your first game of the Jets was
in San Diego right and and in front of
the whole country on Monday Night
Football and you're sitting there
watching even though you know somewhat
of mark Ingram's caliber is is worthy of
the carries on the goal line well I mean
how did you go through all of that with
the Jets
LT yeah that's a good question I think
you know for me I was realistic about my
role on that team you know I went in and
I knew that that you know Shawn green
day he was going to be the starter they
drafted him to be the started there and
I would be a guy to do third downs
mostly but also you know kind of fill in
and you
things change obviously my first year
you know then you can go according to
plan I end up being starter and all
those kinds of things but initially it's
about the - average I went intense this
is who I'm gonna be and I'm okay with
that I knew I still would have a
prominent role on that team you know as
a pass catcher coming out the backfield
and so in this case I think I really
believe Adrien expected to have at least
15 to 20 carries especially going back
to Minnesota and so when that didn't
happen I think that's what what you seen
the frustration of him kind of yelling
then it's Sean Payton and say hey let's
run the football give me involved and
let me ask you this el-tee you know you
were drafted very high than in the draft
and then we didn't see many running
backs go top five now he saw Zeke
Elliott go top five last year and what
he did for the Cowboys turning things
around now we're seeing fournette go in
the same spot he had a great week one
Kareem hunt a spectacular week one we're
seeing all these young running backs
Dalvin cook Christian McCaffrey even
tarik Cohen with Chicago how do you
think we're seeing a new Advent and a
new wrinkle in this copycat league where
kids come from college and can shine at
the runningback spot right away I think
so more particularly I think in the pass
game you know they're they are more
advanced I believe in a past game from a
lot of these systems that are in college
football right now you know so running
the football I mean it doesn't require a
lot to be able to carry the football me
great instincts reactions and all those
kinds of things is something that can
help you as a young guy and to be able
to sustain that you got it you got to
grow you got evolved into being a guy to
read defenses and all those kind of
things but initially as a runner it's
not very hard what's hard is
understanding the pass game and the fact
that these guys are doing it in the pass
game right now it's pretty impressive
their ability
and I think it bodes well for the future
of the game that the running back
position that these guys can now come in
right away and be able to contribute in
a passing game like the light they have
been um so for a few more minutes with
LaDainian Tomlinson courtesy of FedEx
here on the Rich Eisen show you know the
next man mentality is a real thing
within locker rooms in the NFL outside
of it folks like us in the media and
fantasy football players watch David
Johnson go down and think the Cardinals
are toast
for 2017 what do you think about David
Johnson's injury that might keep him out
until December if not indefinitely oh
man is so unfortunate it really is
because this guy was getting ready to
take off you know he was a huge part of
that all sense probably can say he was
going to be about 40% of that offense
and now not to have him there there is
nobody that you can get to you know to
to do what he has done and can do they
just don't make guys like him every
single day and you can't find them off
the streets you can't train for them and
so I'll tell you I agree with you I
think there's going to be an uphill
battle for the Arizona Cardinals because
they have to be able to run the football
and then I love Carson but the way
Carson look in week one I don't think
they're gonna be able to loan on the
passing game they're not gonna be able
to beat people throw on the football so
ask him the poll question before we get
to a FedEx Brocklin go for it
yeah well dannion which one a no team
right now is the biggest smoke screen
bills Jags
Rams Ravens I'm not gonna say the Jags
because that was pretty impressive their
men's defense their planet yeah they're
playing good defense they can run the
football you know I'm gonna go with the
Rams you know just because I don't know
yet you know what this team's gonna be
about and in that division you know to
me is still about Seattle Seattle is
going to be the head of that division
and um golf you know I want to see a
little bit more from he look good in
week one obviously but he was playing
against the Colts so and I just being
honest I know I'm an analyst but I can't
name one player in the coast defense
guys yeah I can't know
Vontae Davis is hurt so who I don't know
who's else is out there so I'm gonna fit
around all right el-tee
now tell me about it's the the annual
FedEx air and ground Player of the Week
and tell me about the donation that's
involved as well season rich of earned
ground program that FedEx is doing and
so you know a little bit about it but
each week you can the fans can vote on
the best performances from the
quarterback and running back position
and they can vote via Twitter hashtag
air and ground or go online
nfl.com slash FedEx for the best
quarterback and running back
performances and also FedEx will make a
two thousand donation to the USO and
both the winning quarterback and the
running backs name each week of the
regular season so if you're mad guy
that's four thousand dollars each week
going to the uso program that's pretty
good alright LT you the man I'll see you
back at the shop all right that's what
Danny Thomas and Pro Football Hall of
Famer from NFL network as well as FedEx
nfl.com / FedEx Rich Eisen show weekdays
at noon eastern on radio stations across
the country and audience
if you liked that video be sure to
download our app and I'll be sure to
move week six games to Saturday for that
wedding you have to go to